six one seven eight three zero 47 50
let's go to our next caller from the
five one three area code caller from
five one three go ahead hello that's you
yeah who is this yeah my name is John
okay go ahead John yeah I was just
wondering why you think Bernie Sanders
identifies as a Democratic Socialist
sort of a social democrat does he just
not know I mean I know there's a lot of
confusion because a lot of even
Scandinavian countries call themselves
democratic socialist countries but there
really are social democracies yeah
already still same or does Bernie
stylist publicans can play off this
sorry what was your question I'm just
wondering why you think Bernie Sanders
called identifies the Democratic
Socialist instead of Social Democrat I'm
not sure that he still does like do you
know Pat does Bernie still say I am a
democratic social not as much as they
used to but I think he does because he
talked about how he's a socialist but
he's a Democratic Socialist so there's a
big difference there I think he does
still identify as one yeah I mean if
that's the case then he's adding to the
confusion you know if he is saying now
it's also possible that Bernie actually
is a true socialist but in with regard
to how he works as a senator he may be
advocating for social democracy because
really the policies that he's proposed
medicare-for-all in the college
education plan and and minimum wage
those are more indicative of social
democracy than socialism so he may well
be an actual socialist but he's you're
right that he's mostly advocating for
policies of social democracy well I just
have a quick second question if you ever
had Bernie Sanders on would you ask him
why identify some offensive yes I will
every now and then I would all right
thank you thank you appreciate the call
if you're holding please don't hang up
we're going to take a quick break and
get right back to the phones after this
don't hang up if you're holding we're
taking more calls